now labour has suggested it does support
the lifting restrictions on july the
19th
but sakia starman will still warn this
week that the government's approach
could lead to a summer of chaos and
confusion
let's find out where labour really
stands on everything we've been
discussing so far we're joined by one of
zakir's
holding midfielders the party's shadow
education secretary
kate green kate green um
would you support the reduction of an
interval between
the first and second jabs if the jcvi
were to recommend it i know we heard
from nadim zahavi
he's not thinking about it but it's
obviously in the air
clearly if there is advice from the jcvi
that that would be a safe and sensible
measure we've always said
that it's right to act on the advice and
clearly the vaccination program has been
a hugely important
tool in our ability to combat the virus
but the priority of course now is also
to make sure that people who have not
been vaccinated at all
and get the vaccine and it is concerning
that the rate of vaccinations
is slowing and that some groups have
still not been able to come forward and
be vaccinated and so i think the
priority has got to be to spread the
vaccine
program to the maximum so that we keep
everyone as safe as possible
this is interesting because um you
you're now telling me that you're
worried about the pace of vaccination
which we see slowing down as i discussed
with the minister
sakir described the government's course
as
reckless yet as far as we understand it
labor is supporting
the government's decision to lift
restrictions on july the 19th
isn't that a bit like saying that the
driver's
gone a bit bonkers but we are completely
content to let him
drive us into the ditch well we do want
to see the restrictions lifted on the
19th subject to the data and i think
we're still waiting for that final data
um in the coming day or two um
but what we don't want is to lift the
restrictions without keeping mitigations
in place
that would enable that to happen more
safely so for example that's
why we've said that the mandatory mass
squaring should continue in public
places it's why we've said
that there should be more support and
requirement on public spaces
uh to have proper ventilation systems
that's why we've said
that the financial support for people on
low incomes who have to isolate
needs to be adequate so that they can
afford to do that so yes we do want to
see the restrictions lifted if the data
confirmed that that's
uh the right thing to do and i i hope
another indication seemed to be that it
that it will do um but we want that
with the the mitigations kept in place
okay well
let's test this this out a little bit
and take a concrete example
um you just raised the question of mask
discipline
now what the government's going to do is
allow people to
go to night clubs abandon social
distancing
uh and the rule of thirty no requirement
for nightclubs now
it may be that you and i won't be
particularly vulnerable
to that i don't know you know how how we
might spend our fridays and saturday
nights uh next month
but is it your idea that as long as we
keep marks on
it doesn't matter how up close and
personal we get in nightclubs
well first of all trevor i'm not one of
the world's great clubbers i wish you'd
asked me the old trafford question since
i'm sitting just i'm coming
don't worry we will get there good
excellent
but you know it's masks are not the only
protection and
venues will be looking at putting in
place a whole range of mitigations and
it's absolutely
right that they should and that they
should be subject to the proper health
and safety requirements that are placed
on them
but you know masks we've just heard from
syrian diamonds people want to wear
masks most people feel more comfortable
and confident
when others are wearing masks around
them and i think this oh we'll leave it
up to individuals people can take
personal responsibility
that's a recipe for confusion i'm afraid
it's probably
a recipe for more confrontations um and
i just think it would be much clearer
and simpler for the government to keep
mandatory mask wearing
in public places uh in place after the
19th of july
but what what why don't you guys follow
through then
and say look you know what the
nightclubs
we're not ready for that why don't you
just
have the courage of your convictions and
say that
i think it is very important that we get
the balance between health and
um people's economic well-being which
after all is an important factor in good
health
get that balance right and of course we
know that the uh hospitality and
entertainment sector has suffered
terribly in this pandemic
i am concerned that we should respond
very quickly to
any new data we receive and uh that's
um that all the protections that we can
put in place
are put in place and i'm going back to
your first point trevor
it is really important especially if the
typical clubber is probably younger
that we make sure that that vaccination
program reaches
everybody who should be receiving a
vaccine and particularly young people
so that we make everyone as safe as
possible okay let me just
try one last test of your position and
this is something you can't
uh get put on the government um
the two mayors of the largest
uh cities or first and third largest
cities
uh sadiq khan and andy burnham
have the tube and the tram under their
control
will they be requiring a mandatory
mask on those uh forms of transport
it's in their hands what is labour going
to say about that
i hope they will and i believe i'm i
think i'm right and saying that andy has
already
indicated that here in manchester that's
what he will do
um i certainly think that um having
traveled regularly on both the tube and
the tram
um all through the um pandemic when i
was allowed to
that wearing masks and seeing other
others wearing masks is a source of
great reassurance and people want to do
it
okay uh the old trafford question
manchester united playing leads 14th of
august
um are you fine with 74 000 people
turning up
most of them without masks well as
sirian said i don't think we know that
it's most of them without masks and i do
know having a long-standing relationship
with manchester united they're in my
constituency here
um that they will go to great lengths to
to keep people safe
and make sure that protections and
mitigations are in place
are you you're going to be there right
no i'm not sadly i'm this ticket you're
offering if it's still going spare you
know send it my way but um
i would really encourage people who are
going to that game to keep themselves
and others around them safe and please
wear a mask and follow the instructions
that stewards are giving you
um because you know it's it's outdoors
there's less risk of infection spreading
when you are outdoors as
as we know but i think every measure
that we can take we should take
uh to defeat this terrible virus okay
you you've issued a statement today
about the government's plans for
legislation against hate speech
in higher education and
what you said or what the party has said
in its
release is labor say the law is trying
to solve the problem doesn't exist
uh let me read you some names jk rowling
julie bindle amber rudd selena todd
kevin price uh you know what they've all
got in common they have all been
cancelled in fact one of them's lost
their job over the what they have said
about the issue of women as a sex
uh as opposed to um the the view that's
taken by some
trans rights activists that uh there is
no such thing essentially
now are you really saying that there is
nothing to see here this problem doesn't
exist
there are and always have been a small
a very small number of instances and
i think those uh examples that you gave
um in many cases perhaps in all cases
i'm not familiar with every single one
of those examples trevor
uh well please but trevor
last in the last year for which we have
data out of 10 000 events
only six were cancelled four because
they had the wrong paperwork
one went to another venue one was a
pyramid scheme if you look across the
piece
there are a very small number of events
that are cancelled i think there is
obviously a concern about the atmosphere
the climate on campus
but that cuts both ways and if we have
as i believe this legislation does
um a law that allows people actually to
come on campus as
holocaust deniers to spread hate speech
anti-faxers
i don't think that's in the public
interest and i think that has a chilling
effect and i think
we don't need this legislation we
already have faithful
on campus in law and i think that this
actually
gives sucker to people who want to sow
hate and division
and to their lawyers they'll be running
off particularly
on the basis of a small number of cases
if i may say so you say it's a small
number of cases
but for every individual who is fired
because of what they have said
it's a hundred percent so let me just
ask you again
is the labor view it that nothing to see
here
i'm not saying there are no cases at all
what i am saying is
it's a very small number of incidents
when you look at the number of events
that have gone ahead
quite satisfactorily on campus and that
we already have
satisfactory legislation we've had it
going back to the 1986 education act
and then strengthened i would say by
labour's human rights act
what we don't need is legislation that
now allows holocaust deniers
anti-vaxxers people spreading hate
speech
to run off to the courts if a student
union or university says
okay all right um i don't want that and
i don't think
okay kate green i know you know a lot
about education but i think you know
quite a lot about football as well
what's a score tonight
what is going on here uh that
are we now a country of snowflakes who
can't even predict our own victory
i will make it i will
okay apparently um viewers the line
has frozen oh i'm i'm being told
kate is about winning come on kate
quickly
thank you kate green